in the last video we learned Coulomb's
law told us that the static electric
force between two particles is equal to
Coulomb's constant which is you know K
is equal to 9 times 10 to the 9th what
was it it was it was let's see we want
to get Newton's meter squared per
Coulomb squared times the charge in on
the first object of the first point
charge times the second charge divided
by the distance between them so that's
great if we if I gave you both charges
you could figure out the force and and
you knew how far apart they were well
what if I only gave you one of them and
I said well you know I'm gonna give you
one charge and you know do as much math
as you want and then I'm gonna later
give you a bunch of other charges and
then I want you to figure out the force
well then you could kind of do your work
ahead of time and you could say well if
I just have one charge here so let's
just say I have one charge I don't know
let's call that charge let's call it big
Q although we could have called it
little Q if we have one charge there
let's figure out ahead of time what the
force would be if I'm given another
charge later on so what am I saying so
if this this the force between this
charge and another charge is going to be
let's let's call the other charge the
imaginary charge that's not there yet
let's call that Q two so we already know
what the force on between these two are
it's going to be so the the force is
going to be Coulomb's constant times big
Q which is the the charge that we're
given or that we're starting off with
times Q 2 divided by the distance
squared right at that point if Q 2 is
right there but I just said you know we
don't know what Q 2 is we just want to
enough math ahead of time so that when
someone gives us a Q 2 we can very
quickly at any point in space figure out
what the force would be so to do that we
can essentially just say is well well
then what is the force per charge so
let's divide both sides of this equation
by Q 2 and like I'll get rid of this
little sub because I think it'll just
infuse things so the force per charge
per whatever wherever q2 is and whatever
q2 is we don't know what it is is going
to be equal to K times whatever my
charge is divided by d squared right
wherever that charge I place it however
far it is that's D divided by d squared
and this is called the electric field
generated by this charge discharge big Q
and what does that do how does that help
us well if you think about it we could
let me do it in fact instead of just
thinking about it if I were to draw that
charge let's say it's a point charge
right here that's Q and then we could
say at any point at any point if I were
to place a charge how strong is the
force going to be because we can just